years on from setting up the UK Health
Security Agency can I ask the obvious
question first what does it actually do
well we're here to protect lives to save
livelihoods we have a a remit to protect
the population against not just
infectious disease but other external
Health threats so chemical radiation
environmental hazards it's a new
organization those things always
happened in the UK but there is a
particular focus on it now and we're
able I think more obviously to deploy
our scientific skills particularly I
mean you were set up in the middle of
covid it's been a bit of a journey I can
imagine
I think that's a fair description when
I'm talking to people and often they'll
ask me that question I say it's been a
very exciting time it's a bit like um an
exaggerated action learning set so uh
obviously we were put up as a new
organization in the middle of a pandemic
to fight pandemics and that's one of our
principal focuses but nevertheless
sitting at the back of this is a
considerable round of work that goes on
routinely that I think many of the
public are not aware of so routines
events of huge numbers of infectious
diseases as well as operational
capability to respond to health threats
for example just recently you've seen
the the Dorset leakage for example that
was our Southwest Health Protection Team
sorting cooperating with blue light
services on oil leakage in a harbor so a
whole host of things ongoing all the
time if you're talking about kind of
upcoming threats and challenges is there
anything that you've got your eye on
that you're particularly worried about
we are reviewing this at the moment
because I think it's important as a new
agency that we have a very systematic
approach perhaps in a new way that the
country hasn't had there's always been a
national risk assessment ongoing
continuously but I think what we've seen
with covid is a new focus and
understanding of how severe and how
significant infectious disease
particularly can be not just in the UK
but globally as well to our lives but
also our livelihoods so both the health
and economic costs if we look back a few
months we knew about monkeypox mpox for
example it's not a new virus but the way
that it has spread recently in terms of
much wider transmission remains an
ongoing concern but then if we look
forward of course we're now talking
about Avian Influenza again not a new
risk we've known about but one where we
are starting to see some changes in
potentially a mammalian transmission not
yet in humans so with avian inflict with
something you're specifically looking at
just in case it does start to become a
restitution absolutely and if any of
your viewers want to look one of the key
aims of the organization is to be as
transparent as we possibly can with data
and with our knowledge and so one of the
things we've become quite famous for uh
possibly internationally more than in
the UK is our technical briefings how
much of a risk is it to humans so the
risk to humans at the moment has not
changed and that's what you'll you'll
see there but what we are starting to
look at is the change we obviously have
genomic sequencing now which gives us
much more insight into how viruses are
changing and we're starting to look at
changes a little small changes in
mammalian Transmissions so we've had for
example Spanish mink farms and and a few
seals but I think the general message to
people is this for human risk it hasn't
changed at all but it's definitely
something we're keeping an eye on now
because you're not spokesperson for the
NHS but Health Services always impact
each other it's it's it's they're not
independent if you like and I know a lot
of our viewers are worried about the
state of the NHS you know we've had a
difficult winter with strep a with flu
with covid of course and pressures on on
doctors
and I just want to take the opportunity
as I've got someone who isn't a
politician in the chair and can give me
a bit more of a neutral response how
worried should we be about the state of
the National Health Service so you're
right I'm not a politician I am the
doctor and it gives me a great
opportunity actually to give a caller
and thank you to all my clinical
colleagues working on the front line
right through covert but as you said
particularly through recent incidents
um I mean obviously the overall
strategic approach to NHS management is
very much for politicians I think what
we've seen over this winter though is
something which we could partially
predict but was difficult to understand
uh the detail overhead so you've
mentioned I guess so invasive group a
streptococcal disease what we've seen
with that is a different seasonality for
it and do you think that's because of
covert because of the law almost
certainly we've got high degrees of
uncertainty where infectious diseases
will overlap with each other so what
we're seeing this year is which we
didn't want but had planned for was flu
interacting exactly the same time as a
covered Peak so we have them together
we've had a group a strep coming earlier
and we've had RSV restrictions in Cydia
virus which we'd normally see earlier
coming a little bit later and how is the
health of the NHS itself because these
kind of challenges are going to come up
do you think it's in a good place
I'm not working directly on the front
line though so I think those questions
are much better asked of Representatives
directly I I do know that colleagues are
working super hard and I think the
important thing for me is getting shared
understanding of what we're expecting
using our data which we have done this
winter to help colleagues on the front
line and in management predict what
services might be impacted now it's
weird because for me it almost feels
like covert's a bit of a bad dream like
I can't really believe it actually
happened
um is that Fairview or am I actually
completely wrong and covert is still
actually a very real threat it's very
much here it's going to be a threat in
the same way that flu is a threat flu is
still at the top of our national risk
assessment in case it changes and we
have a flu pandemic so I wouldn't like
to think it had gone away but what we
have done and the living with covert
policy says is using vaccines
particularly but new treatments as well
we have largely got it under control at
the moment
um I think your approach to it was a bad
dream many people feel this as a natural
psychology that says when some large
event has happened and we've all worked
our way through it it's nice to forget
it I think it's my responsibility
leading the ukh to say not to forget
that and make sure we learn lessons from
it identify those and put them into
action to talk about those lessons you
mentioned the vaccines which many would
say that's the big success of academic
response what do you think was the
biggest mistake
um so there's a public inquiry ongoing
and we're contributing to that along
with everyone else we want to learn from
things that could have been done better
but I think there's a lot of retro
retrospector scoping ongoing at the
moment and that's quite dangerous what
we want is objective evidence of where
we can do things better going forward I
think what we're trying to take forward
is being more prepared about things that
we can be but also using new science and
new techniques so you know your your
three-year bad dream has probably
included you grabbing a test kit from
the post and putting it up in your nose
sending it back using intellectual
photos those sorts of things were not
available and not used by the public
prior to coving so we're better prepared
for future pandemics and we can use
those techniques for other infectious
disease and so I think there are
opportunities there in what we can do
going forward I'm going to try and again
if I may because you know you're being
very good science stuff in the questions
I'm going to wait for the public inquiry
and we don't want to be too
retrospective but you must have some
views on on the response and you know
we've got a lot of scrutiny on the Prime
Minister on the former prime minister
Boris Johnson as well is there do you
think that what would is your main top
so you would not expect me to comment on
individuals or politicians I don't think
that you'd expect that I think there are
lessons and many of them actually about
some of the learning and guidance for
somebody like me or a CMO whether it's
UK abroad have been published in a
document which have contributed to on
technical lessons which is probably our
area and I think there are things that
we can do firstly about preparedness a
getting testing set up that's not as
easy as it sounds so developing things
like panaceas which is a a sort of
technical way of saying we can have a
broad test and then we can hone it down
refine it when we have more detail I
think some of the areas where we've
learned is we've had very little
knowledge about environmental
transmission before and we need to do
that we need to factor into building
designs for example going forward as
well and one thing that worries me about
the impact of covid is public skepticism
around vaccines and the anti-vaxx
movement online not just in related to
covid vaccines but also other really
important vaccines like childhood
vaccines for example is that something
that's concerned so there are a couple
of things here I think people have had a
bad time for the last three years and
actually we're almost seeing a little
bit of vaccine fatigue I mean I would
just like to highlight to people
particularly the most vulnerable uh the
very elderly that that is the
life-saving intervention people
absolutely but we've also seen over
recent years not just recently a
drop-off in primary childhood
vaccination and of course people have
forgotten the importance of that so
we've seen recently the emergence in so
cases for example of polio paralysis
from polio in Israel and the US and I
think these are strong reminders that we
need to boost our childhood vaccination
not remove them I mean Polo it's one of
those things where you you think it's
almost been eradicated and then you have
that with other childhood illnesses as
well is there evidence that some of
these things are starting to resurface
here so the particular case we've got
now is because in some cases overseas
lie live virus vaccines are used that's
not what we use routinely here but then
we can have odd cases being coming into
the country and if you don't have a
properly vaccinated population then they
can change and and actually cause polio
themselves so the real trick here is
just get your children vaccinated for
polio and they are protected now you're
a scientist or you're a doctor and but
you were suddenly thrust into the public
eye in a very extreme way
um I think during the covid-19 pandemic
it became one of the most recognizable
people thanks to those daily press
conferences how was that
slightly strange not my natural place to
go and immediately project myself
forward on a number 10 Podium but lots
of learning and actually is a very
privileged responsible position as well
what I hope I was able to do alongside
politicians was speak directly to
members of the public who perhaps were
Keen to hear from scientists and from
clinicians themselves and I know from
feedback I get that I have to meet
people and they say oh I think it feels
like we know you already you've been in
our sitting room there have been one of
two strange moments as well I've had a
chicken named after me for example
chicken a chicken and just this week
we've had a day with industry trying to
work on those Pathways to new vaccine
development and somebody who attended
our ukhsa putting down offices settle my
daughter has a teddy bear named after
you these are these are not things I
would have anticipated when I entered
medical were you a bit worried that is
there any what's that from Matt Hancock
might Thruster on the front pages again
uh well I I try and exactly as I should
as a civil servant and always keep
unbiased in what I do